all right welcome back everyone to my
round 8 recap from the Qatar
Masters I'm definitely feeling some
turnament fatigue uh it's been eight
pretty hardfought games so far and this
game was a super interesting battle so I
do apologize if I slur my words or just
appear tired but uh yeah I think the
goal is to get through this recap find
some food and then get some sleep
because the round starts earlier
tomorrow but let's hop into the game I
was playing International Master shyam n
from India and coming into this game I
was expecting KN F3 on move one uh but
my opponent slightly surprised me with
Pawn to G3 uh which I can't remember the
last time I I encountered this move in a
serious over theboard classical game but
uh the thing about G3 is usually it will
transpose into some kind of ready or
English or Cath
so I play D5 here and after Knight F3
Knight F6 Bishop G2 E6 Castle Bishop E7
uh D3 this is now a Kings Indian attack
from uh the white side and this is one
of the main things I was expecting
before the game so uh I still was in
prep I played Pawn to C5 opponent plays
Knight to D2 I play Knight C6 and
someone is messaging me but uh sorry
someone I'll have to get back to you
later so after Knight C6 my opponent
plays Pawn to E4 and this is basically
the main position I Was preparing before
the game and here there's a lot of
different approaches for black I played
uh what I think is one of the more
flexible options is Queen to C7 and
there are ideas of in some cases cting
queenside uh basically I don't want to
commit to castling kingside too early
but after Rook T1 I played B6 and here
my opponent played uh I don't think is a
main line he took on D5 now if white
plays Pawn E5 I would play Knight to D7
and this would be a case where black
could consider casting Queen side um and
then enter a middle game where white
doesn't really have the traditional
Kings in need attack on the king side
because my king would be on the Queen's
side so I was ready to go for positions
like that but after Pawn takes Pawn uh
the strategy changes uh a bit cuz I take
back with knight uh my opponent plays
Knight to E4 and when we got to this
position I was still feeling good
because I had this exact position on my
computer this morning before the round
and I knew that in my prep file I had to
move Bishop to B7 uh but for some reason
during the game I began thinking and I
thought that there's really no
difference if I play Bishop B7 first or
Castle first I knew these moves are um
basically coming next so during the game
I made an instinctive decision to Castle
first I thought it was maybe slightly
more flexible and after I played this
move I instantly regretted it because my
opponent thought for a bit and played
the move Pawn to C4 and then I realized
why I should have played Bishop B7 first
is white is now trying to exploit this
diagonal and even though there's a lot
of things between this bishop and my
Rook on eight very soon we're going to
see that black is under some serious
serious pressure now after C4 I took my
first think of the game and for good
portion of my uh my think here I was
just regretting having not played Bishop
B7 right away
but uh yeah I ultimately played Knight
to F6 and the issue here is white just
starts throwing punches uh my opponent
plays Bishop F4 attacking my queen my
queen doesn't really have too many great
squares play Queen to D7 and then my
opponent hits me with Knight to E5 and
for a brief moment I thought that I
might just be losing out of the opening
because it just seems like there's a lot
of tactics that are going in White's
favor there's now tension between all
the knights on the board and um of
course the tension still on the long
diagonal but as I began to calculate
here I gradually realized that black
should be okay and the move I play is
Knight takes E5 and I want to note here
that I was okay with Knight takes F6 and
even in the event where I lose my Rook
on A8 I can take on D3 and I'm pretty
sure this is totally fine for black uh
maybe black is even for choice in this
position so instead of uh Knight takes
F6 my opponent played Bishop takes E5
and after takes takes it still looks
pretty scary because my rook's attacked
and these Bishops are uh very much ready
to try and exploit my king side I don't
really have too many Defenders on the
king side but thankfully here I have the
move Bishop to B7 just offering the
trade of light Square Bishops and it
turns out that it's not so easy for
white to get any sort of quick attack
now I do want to note here there's a
funny line white could consider taking
on H7 playing Queen H5 and then sagging
another Bishop um this is maybe a
thematic idea in some sorts of positions
uh known as a double Bishop sacrifice to
then someday checkmates with Swinging
The Rook over but in this case it
doesn't work because I'm controlling uh
E4 Square so there's no Rook E4 and I
don't think white even has a draw here
because yeah in the event of this I can
eventually block Queen G4 with Bishop
G5 so I wasn't scared of Bishop takes H7
and instead here my opponent plays Queen
to G4 uh threatening
checkmates and it does look still very
scary and if I played the move F6 I
think this would be very bad for black
because after takes takes white can take
the pawn with check and then save the
bishop so after Queen G4 I think I had
to play G6 no other real option and then
my opponent takes on B7 I take back and
then plays Bishop to C3 and now the um
position has actually simplified pretty
substantially over last few moves and I
kind of breathed a sigh of relief
however I still had to to work very hard
in this position as we're going to see
cuz white has this really annoying Dart
for Bishop piercing through the position
and my pieces are a little bit misplaced
here my Bishop is not so happy on E7 my
queen and Rooks are not on the best
squares so my plan going forward from
here um I started with rook fd8 and I
really just wanted to neutralize White's
Bishop with bishop f8 and Bishop G7 and
then my plan later
going into the middle game was to Target
White's backward Pawn on D3 but my
opponent did not make my life easy and
he started with Queen to E2 and at first
this looks like a passive retreating
move but he's threatening Queen E5 and I
had to be really really careful here
because if I play one careless move then
Queen E5 and yeah I don't think black is
surviving this so after Queen E2 I
basically had to prevent the idea of
Queen to E5 I played the move Queen to
C7 and then my opponent plays Queen to
F3 so he is uh being kind of annoying
cuz now my plan of Bishop f8 doesn't
work because Queen F6 and it's still a
question how do I neutralize White's
Bishop on C3 so here I started with the
move Rook to C8 which I thought is a
very useful move preparing Queen C6 to
offer the queen trade and I thought here
that if I can trade Queens then
positioning black should be much better
with just better Pawn structure White
having the long-term weakness on D3 but
it was still hard to neutralize because
here my opponent plays Pawn H4 and it's
very clear that he wants to just storm
the H Pawn and create some weakness on
my king side I respond with Queen C6 and
after Queen to E3 he's still threatening
to create the Queen Bishop battery so I
move to D6 and then he plays Pawn to H5
and around here I thought that I'm under
serious serious pressure because white
has ideas of taking and then if I take
back with H Pawn then the queen can come
in and yeah G7 and h8 are both potential
checkmating squares but in this position
I began to calculate and I found a NIC
looking line that ended up happening in
the game and it started with Bishop f8
preparing Bishop to
G7 and here my opponent prevents me from
UM playing Bishop G7 by playing H6 it
still looks very uncomfortable with this
Pawn um just kind of a nail in my
position and now it's the question how
do I ever get my Bishop to the long
diagonal but it turns out here that I
have a u I think a nice simplifying move
is Pawn to E5 and after the game game my
opponent told me that he had overlooked
this move and the reason why Pawn E5 I
think is very nice for black is because
it essentially offers to trade E Pawn
for H Pawn or E Pawn for D pawn and
basically if he takes with the queen I'm
very happy to trade queens and then take
and then just have a better end game and
then what happened in the game he took
with the bishop but then I take on D3
and essentially getting uh the trade of
Queens it's hard for white to avoid it
he did try with Queen F4 preparing Queen
F6 but I'm in time to play Queen F5 and
then very quickly things just head
towards the end game he takes on F5 I
take and now the H Pawn is more of a
weakness than it is a strength he plays
Bishop F4 and I play Rook to C6 so now
it's guaranteed I'll be winning the pawn
on H6 and and once we got to this
position I was breathing a sigh of
relief cuz I really thought I was under
a lot of pressure in the middle game and
going forward from here I thought I had
maybe some chances to play for a win
given that it looks like black is
winning a pawn and after he plays Rook
D1 we trade Rooks and I do win the pawn
on
H6 uh but then he gets some counterplay
he starts with Bishop to B8 I play A6
and then he plays Pawn to B3 so even
though I'm up a pawn here White's
remaining pawns are all very solid and
White's also controlling the defile and
my rook and Bishop are not the most
active of pieces so I found it hard to
actually see where if at all I have any
advantage and I tried to make some
improvements here I started with King to
G7 he plays Pawn A4 and I play King to
F6 uh and then he plays Rook to d8 so
he's getting a lot of um active play
with his rook and Bishop and maybe
there's ideas of Rook h8 but he also has
ideas of Bishop A7 and Rook B8 to Target
The Pawn on B6 so here I played Bishop
to C1 which is a weird looking move at
first but I basically just wanted to get
my Bishop to a happier Square in the
center and after he plays Bishop A7 I
played Bishop to B2 and I actually
offered a draw here because I thought
what was going to happen is just going
to lead to a drawn ending and rather
than playing it out my opponent actually
accepted the draw so the game did end
here very peacefully and I'll take a
moment just to share what I was
calculating and then we'll check with
the engine so I was expecting if he were
to play on he' play Rook to B8 I was
going to play Bishop to E5 uh attacking
The Rook essentially forcing white to
win back the pawn and then I thought
that this resulting position is just a
pretty clear draw I was calculating F4
King G6 King F2 King H5 King F3 and then
I would wait and I don't think there's
any way for either side to make
reasonable
progress so anyway um yeah I I think I'm
happy with a draw but um I'm not sure if
I was ever better or worse in this game
but let's goad head and check with the
engine I'll switch to other chapter here
and here we have the Moment of
Truth
wow look at
this ah it's so so flat so clean that's
another perfect
game I'm so relieved that I wasn't
losing out of the
opening Let's uh yeah let's let's see
what stockfish has to
say so was cing a mistake on my
part so I was supposed to play Bishop
B7 um
castling I'm actually curious cuz it
doesn't show castling being in
inaccuracy here but I think it was
clearly it's clearly not the best
move but still after C4 imagine the play
was all pretty clean
I was under
pressure did we just both play perfectly
from here H4
eventually yeah I don't think there's so
much more to look at than what I already
like analyzed yeah E5 was the best move
I was still slightly worse according to
the
engine but yeah it's basically just
heading towards a
draw and let's check the final position
B3 my opponent was getting low on time
but I don't think there was any any
chance for me to play for a
win ah maybe I could have tried F4 my
opponent actually told me this after the
game he was scared of
f4 but I was in the mindset just to be
solid engine still giving a quality
after King
G2 so okay can't complain um yeah it's
actually nice to see that even
late in the tournament I'm still capable
of playing a game with no obvious
mistakes so uh yeah after this game I am
now four out of eight on a 50%
score um I think I'm I'm gaining a
little bit of rating this tournament
actually I'm definitely gaining rating
because I'm on 50% against all opponents
higher rated than me so there is one
more game tomorrow uh the game tomorrow
starts to hours earlier than the
previous rounds so I need to eat and
sleep thanks everyone for watching stay
tuned for the final recap and I'll see
you guys soon